la pire crise économique depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale s'ajoute une
crise politique
en plus des conséquences du coc vite 19
sur l'économie du pays
justin trudeau doit faire face à la
suspicion qui pèse sur son ministre des
finances bill morneau est accusé d'avoir
attribué sans appel d'offres un
important contrat gouvernemental à
l'association caritative richard iti qui
a rémunéré sa fille en retour le premier
ministre est lui aussi directement visés
puisque sa mère son frère et son épouse
ont également touché 300 mille dollars
de l'association justin trudeau a
présenté ses excuses mais continue à
démentir tout traitement de faveur
parfois se récuser peut être la bonne
chose à faire même si ce n'est pas
nécessaire ici le lien de ma mère et des
autres membres de ma famille avec
l'association caritative reach hariti
pourrait amener certaines personnes à se
demander si ces liens joué en rôle dans
la décision de choisir oui charity
bien sûr ce n'est pas le cas oui charity
n'a reçu aucun traitement de faveur ni
de moi ni de personne d'autre
il n'a jamais eu de directives de
tentatives d' influence de ma part ou de
celle de mon personnel pour que le
service public recommande l'association
we charity favoriser l'activité des
jeunes a été un de mes objectifs bien
avant que je n'entre en politique je
regrette donc profondément la façon dont
cela s'est déroulé en poste ministère
des finances depuis 2000 15 bill morneau
a quant à lui démissionné de son poste
en début de semaine pour le remplacer et
faire face à la crise économique que
traverse le pays
justin trudeau a fait appel à sa vice
première ministre christy afriland
ancien journaliste et ancien ministre
des affaires étrangères elle avait
participé en 2018 à la renégociation de
l'accord de libre échange nord américain
avec les états unis et le mexique estia
freeland ne cache pas sa fierté de
devenir la première femme ministre des
finances au canada on vit toujours avec
le coronavirus il s'agit d'un défi
unique pour notre pays et notre
engagement en tant que gouvernement et
de faire tout ce qu'il faut pour aider
les canadiens à surmonter ce défi
et au fur et à mesure nous le surmontons
pour reconstruire mieux qu'avant j'ai
conscience que je suis la première femme
ministre des finances du canada
il est grand temps que nous brision ce
plafond de verre bien qu'il reste en
tête dans les sondages la polémique a
fait perdre des points au parti libéral
justin trudeau le 23 septembre prochain
le premier ministre présentera son
programme de relance économique au
parlement
au vu du déficit colossal qu'enregistre
le canada 216 milliards d'euros selon
les projections officielles
la tâche s'annonce ardue pour la
nouvelle ministre des finances